los neoliberales se rasgaron las vestiduras por su precioso equilibrio.
"Si subes el precio de trabajo", advirtieron,
las empresas comprarán menos.
Miles de trabajadores de bajos salarios perderán sus trabajos.
Los restaurantes cerrarán".
Excepto...
que no fue así.
La tasa de desempleo cayó drásticamente.
El negocio de los restaurantes en Seattle floreció.
¿Por qué?
Porque no hay equilibrio.
Porque aumentar los salarios no mata trabajos, los crea;
porque, por ejemplo,
cuando los dueños de restaurantes fueron repentinamente obligados
a pagar a los trabajadores del restaurante lo suficiente
para que ahora incluso "ellos" pudieran darse el lujo de comer en restaurantes,
eso no redujo el negocio, sino que obviamente lo ayudó a crecer.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
La segunda suposición
es que el precio de algo siempre es igual a su valor,
que básicamente significa que si Uds. ganan USD 50 000 al año
y yo gano USD 50 millones al año,
eso es porque yo produzco mil veces más valor que Uds.
Ahora,
no les sorprenderá saber
que esta es una suposición muy reconfortante
para el director ejecutivo de la empresa que gana USD 50 millones al año
pero paga a sus trabajadores salarios de pobreza.
Por favor, escuchen esto de alguien que ha dirigido decenas de negocios:
esto no tiene sentido.
A las personas no se les paga lo que valen.
Se les paga por el poder de negociar,
y la caída de los salarios en el PIB
no es porque los trabajadores se han vuelto menos productivos
sino porque los empleadores se han vuelto más poderosos.
Y...
(Aplausos)
Al fingir que no existe un desequilibrio gigante de poder
entre capital y trabajo,
la teoría económica neoliberal se convirtió esencialmente
en la protección para los ricos.
La tercera suposición, y hasta ahora la más perniciosa,
es un modelo de comportamiento
que describe a los seres humanos como algo llamado "Homo economicus",
que básicamente significa que todos somos perfectamente egoístas,
perfectamente racionales e implacablemente auto-maximizadores.
Pero solo pregúntense:
¿Es plausible que en toda su vida,
cada vez hicieron algo agradable para otra persona
lo hicieron porque estaban maximizando la propia utilidad?
¿Es plausible que cuando un soldado salta sobre una granada
para defender a otros soldados,
lo esté haciendo solo por interés propio?
Si creen que eso es descabellado
y contrario a cualquier intuición moral razonable,
es porque lo es
y, según lo último en la ciencia,
no es cierto.
Este modelo de comportamiento
que está en el corazón frío y cruel de la economía neoliberal,
es moralmente corrosivo
y científicamente incorrecto
porque si aceptamos al pie de la letra
que los humanos somos fundamentalmente egoístas,
y luego vemos alrededor del mundo
la verdadera prosperidad que hay en ella,
entonces por definición lógica y cierta,
los actos de egoísmo de miles de millones de individuos
se convierten mágicamente en prosperidad y bienestar común.
Si los humanos somos simplemente maximizadores egoístas,
entonces el egoísmo es la causa de nuestra prosperidad.
Bajo esta lógica económica
la codicia es buena,
ampliar la desigualdad es eficiente,
y el único propósito de la corporación
puede ser enriquecer a los accionistas,
porque hacer lo contrario sería frenar el crecimiento económico
y dañar la economía en general.
Este evangelio del egoísmo
forma la piedra angular ideológica de la economía neoliberal,
una forma de pensar que ha producido políticas económicas
que me han permitido a mí y a mis amigos ricos
del 1 % superior
obtener todos los beneficios de crecimiento en los últimos 40 años.
Pero,
si en cambio
aceptamos la última investigación empírica,
la ciencia real, que correctamente describe a los seres humanos
como altamente cooperativos,
recíprocos
e criaturas morales por intuición,
entonces, lógicamente,
debe ser la cooperación
y no el egoísmo
la causa de nuestra prosperidad,
y no es el interés propio
sino la reciprocidad inherente
el superpoder económico de la humanidad.
Entonces, en el corazón de esta nueva economía
está la historia que nos da el permiso para ser nuestro mejor yo
y, a diferencia de la vieja economía,
esta es una historia virtuosa
y tiene también la virtud de ser cierta.
Ahora,
quiero enfatizar que esta nueva economía
no es algo que haya personalmente imaginado o inventado.
Se están desarrollando y refinando sus teorías y modelos
en universidades de todo el mundo
con base en lo mejor de lo último en la investigación económica,
de la teoría de la complejidad, la teoría evolutiva,
la psicología, la antropología y otras disciplinas.
Y aunque esta nueva economía aún no tiene su propio libro de texto
o incluso un nombre comúnmente acordado,
a grandes rasgos
así explica de dónde proviene la prosperidad.
El capitalismo de mercado es un sistema evolutivo
en el que la prosperidad emerge
luego de un ciclo de retroalimentación positiva
entre cantidades crecientes de innovación
y cantidades crecientes de demanda del consumidor.
La innovación es el proceso por el cual resolvemos problemas humanos,
la demanda del consumidor es el mecanismo con el que el mercado selecciona
las innovaciones útiles,
y a medida que resolvemos más problemas, nos volvemos más prósperos.
Pero conforme nos volvemos más prósperos,
nuestros problemas y soluciones
se vuelven más complejos,
y esta creciente complejidad técnica
requiere niveles cada vez más altos de cooperación social y económica
para producir los bienes altamente especializados
que definen una economía moderna.
Ahora, la vieja economía es correcta, por supuesto,
porque esa competencia juega un papel crucial
en el funcionamiento de los mercados,
pero no puede ver
que es en gran medida una competencia entre grupos altamente cooperativos...
competencia entre empresas, competencia entre redes de empresas,
competencia entre naciones
y cualquiera que haya manejado alguna vez un negocio exitoso sabe
que construir un equipo cooperativo que incluya los talentos de todos
es casi siempre una mejor estrategia que solo un montón de idiotas egoístas.
Entonces, ¿cómo dejamos atrás el neoliberalismo
y construimos una sociedad más sostenible, más próspera
y más equitativa?
La nueva economía sugiere solo cinco reglas generales.
Primero, las economías exitosas no son selvas sino jardines,
lo que quiere decir que los mercados,
como los jardines, deben ser atendidos,
que el mercado es la mejor tecnología social que se haya inventado
para resolver los problemas humanos,
pero sin las restricciones de las normas sociales
o regulaciones democráticas,
los mercados inevitablemente crean más problemas de los que resuelven.
El cambio climático
y la gran crisis financiera de 2008
son dos ejemplos.
La segunda regla
es que la inclusión crea crecimiento económico.
La idea neoliberal
de que la inclusión es un lujo
solo posible cuando haya crecimiento es incorrecta y está al revés.
La economía es la gente.
Incluir a más personas y de muchas maneras
es lo que genera el crecimiento económico en las economías de mercado.
El tercer principio
es que el propósito de la corporación no es solo enriquecer a los accionistas.
El mayor fraude en la vida económica contemporánea
es la idea neoliberal de que el único propósito de la corporación
y la única responsabilidad de los ejecutivos
es enriquecerse a sí mismos y a los accionistas.
La nueva economía debe y puede insistir
que el propósito de la corporación
es mejorar el bienestar de todos los interesados:
clientes, trabajadores,
comunidad y accionistas por igual.
Regla cuatro:
La codicia no es buena.
Ser rapaz no te hace capitalista,
te hace un sociópata.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
En una economía tan dependiente de la cooperación a escala como la nuestra,
la sociopatía es tan mala para los negocios
como lo es para la sociedad.
Quinto y último:
a diferencia de las leyes de la física,
las leyes de la economía son una elección.
La teoría económica neoliberal
se ha vendido como una ley natural inmutable
cuando, de hecho, son normas sociales y narraciones construidas
con base en pseudociencia.
Si realmente queremos una economía más equitativa,
más próspera y más sostenible,
si queremos democracias y sociedades civiles
que funcionen,
debemos tener una nueva economía.
Y esta es la buena noticia:
si queremos una nueva economía,
solo tenemos que elegir tenerla.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Moderadora: Nick, estoy segura de que te hacen mucho esta pregunta.
Si eres tan infeliz con el sistema económico,
¿por qué no donas todo tu dinero y te unes al 99 %?
Nick Hanauer: Sí, no... sí, claro.
Siempre me lo preguntan.
"Si te importan tanto los impuestos, ¿por qué no pagas más?
Y si te importan tanto los salarios, ¿por qué no pagas más?"
Y podría hacerlo.
El problema
es que no hace mucha diferencia
y he descubierto una estrategia
que funciona literalmente cien mil veces mejor...
Moderadora: Bien.
NH: ...que es usar mi dinero para construir narrativas y aprobar leyes
que requerirá que todas las otras personas ricas
paguen más impuestos y mejor a sus trabajadores.
(Aplausos)
Y así, por ejemplo,
el salario mínimo de USD 15 que promovimos
ha beneficiado a 30 millones de trabajadores.
Eso funciona mejor.
Moderadora: Eso es genial.
Si cambias de idea, te conseguiremos algunos interesados.
NH: Bien. Gracias. Moderadora: Muchas gracias.